hi my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an
agile coach today I will talk about the
agile manifesto the agile manifesto was
written in early 2001 a group of 17 very
opinionated experts specializing in
extreme programming or XP scrum dsdm and
several other frameworks got together
for a weekend working session at a
beautiful ski lodge in Utah
while they didn't agree on much they did
come to agreement on this powerful agile
manifesto
it describes the fundamental values upon
which the principles and practices of
agile will rest if you are effectively
delivering software in total harmony
with these values and the principles you
are agile so what's the manifesto it's
almost poetic goes like this we are
uncovering better ways of developing
software by doing it and helping others
do it through this work we have come to
value individuals and interactions over
processes and tools working software
over comprehensive documentation
customer collaboration over contract
negotiation and responding to change
over following a plan that is while
there's value matters on the right we
value the items on the left more keep
these values in the agile principles in
mind as you inspect and adapt how your
team works together good luck and have
fun